Let's start exploring
intersections with the following.
Given two lines in two dimensions,
where do they intersect?
First, let's make a definition.
Two lines are parallel,
if their normal vectors are parallel.
So for example, these lines are parallel
because their normal vectors differ
by a factor of negative two.
Whereas these two lines are not parallel
because their normal
vectors are not parallel.
It may seem strange that we are using
normal vectors in our definition
instead of direction vectors.
In two dimensions,
the definitions are equivalent.
However, in higher dimensions, there
will not be a single direction vector,
so using the normal vector will
be more extensible later on.
If two lines are not parallel,
then they will have
an intersection at a single point.
However, if two lines are parallel,
then there are two possibilities.
They might not intersect at all, or
they might turn out to be the same line,
so-called coincident lines,
in which case they will intersect
in infinitely many points.
In linear algebra, this trichotomy of
cases for intersections is the rule.
When asked whether two linear objects
intersect, the answer is that there will
either be a unique point of
intersection, there will be no common
intersection or there will be
infinitely many intersection points.
There cannot just be two or
three intersections.
So given two lines in two dimensions,
how can we tell whether
they have an intersection?
Well, first, we should check
whether they are parallel by
looking at their normal vectors.
If their normal vectors are parallel,
then we need to check whether
they are the same line.
How can we do this?
Suppose the two lines are coincident,
that is, the same line.
Then, if I take any point
from the first line and
any point from the second line,
in reality, from the same line,
then the vector connecting the two
points will be parallel to both lines.
In other words,
this vector will be orthogonal
to both lines' normal vectors.
On the other hand, suppose the two lines
are not coincident, but still parallel.
Then these lines have no
common intersections.
So if we pick a point
from the first line and
a point from the second line, then
the vector connecting the two points
won't be in the direction of the lines.
In other words, this connecting vector
won't be orthogonal to either
of the normal vectors.
This gives us a computable test for
whether two lines are the same once
we know that they are parallel.
Two parallel lines are coincident or
equal if and
only if the vector connecting
some pair of points,
one from each line, is orthogonal
to both the lines' normal vectors.
Okay, now let's suppose we
have two nonparallel lines.
So we know they will intersect.
How do we find their intersection point?
Let's write the lines in
their standard forms.
Ax plus By equals k1 and
Cx plus Dy equals k2.
I write this left curly brace to
indicate that this is a system of
simultaneous linear equations.
So how do we go about
solving this system?
It would be nice to divide
the first equation through by A, so
that we can solve for x.
However, what if A equals 0?
Well if that were the case,
we could move to the other equation and
then try dividing this second
equation through by C.
But what if C is also zero?
Actually, that can't happen because
if A and C are both zero, then
the lines are just of the form Y equals
k1 over B, and Y equals k2 over D.
Which are both horizontal lines, but
since we assume the two lines were not
parallel, they both can't be horizontal.
So that means either A or
C has to be non-zero.
To make matter simpler,
let's just do the following at
the beginning of the whole procedure.
We check to make sure
A does not equal zero.
If so, then we swap the order
of the two equations.
So A and C would swap places.
B and D swap places, and
k1 and k2 also swap.
Then we can always assume
that A does not equal zero.
So with that assumption that A is
not zero, we can go ahead and
divide through by A giving us x
plus B over Ay equals k1 over A.
Now instead of solving for
x directly, I'm going to do
something slightly different.
I will now subtract C times
the left hand side of this equation
from the second equation to maintain
the balance of the second equation.
I'll also subtract C times k1
over A from the right-hand
side of the second equation.
So now our second equation looks
like Cx plus Dy minus Cx minus Bc
over Ay equals -Ck1 over A plus k2.
The C terms cancel, and after
collecting the y terms together we get
quantity D minus BC over A times y
equals negative Ck1 over A plus k2.
Now let's multiply through by A to make
the equation a bit nicer to work with,
and then to solve for y, we can divide
through by AD minus BC or can we?
What if AD minus BC equals zero.
Well, if this is the case,
then let's rewrite
the left-hand side as a dot product
using the trick we used before.
This gives us the vector AB dotted
with a vector D minus C equals zero.
Now this first vector is a normal
vector to the first line and
the second vector D minus C is
parallel to the second line.
Looking at this geometrically,
this means that the line Ax plus
By equals k1 is parallel to
the line in the direction of D minus C,
which is Cx plus Dy = k2.
But this violates our initial assumption
that the lines were not parallel.
So AD minus BC cannot equal
zero under this assumption.
Great so that means we can divide
through by AD minus BC, so
y equals negative Ck1 plus Ak2
over the quantity AD minus BC.
Now let's use the same subtraction
process to go from this equation
back to our first equation.
If we subtract B over A times
y from the left-hand side,
then we can subtract B over A times
all of this, from the right-hand side.
This gives us the messy
looking equation,
x = ((k1 / A)- (B / A))
((-Ck1 + Ak2 / AD- BC)).
Let's pull a factor of one over
A to make it a bit cleaner and
then forming a common denominator for
the k1 term allows us to consolidate
the fraction inside the parentheses.
This let's us kill the BCk1 terms and
then cancel the factors of A to
get this final form x equals
Dk1 minus Bk2 all over AD minus BC.
So the point of intersection
of these two lines,
Ax plus By equals k1 and
Cx plus Dy equals k2.
Assuming they are not parallel lines,
is this point x equals Dk1
minus Bk2 over AD minus BC and
y equals -Ck1 plus Ak2 over AD minus BC.
This formula might look rather
messy at first blush, but it
actually exhibits some nice symmetries
that we'll explore a bit later.
For now though let's go ahead and
code up a function to compute this
intersection between two lines.